let's get into a question here's some
guy who looks like he works in the
police department actually with the
windows
he does no he does
it looks like he's in the back of the
car
oh hey guys what's up what's up theo
james from wareham mass i got a little
name game for you
professional wrestlers and i'll start
you off with that
texas rattlestake hitter stone cold
steve austin
gang gang buzz buzz
he is definitely in the back of a cop
car right there yeah he is but he's been
like king and her sting it uh breaking
out of them
key here standing handcuffs they hurt
man dude
one time a buddy of mine got pulled over
he had a pound of weed on him right so
we put it in the front of his pants
the cops take him out of his car put him
into
uh the cop car so they can search his
car yeah
search his car don't find it at the end
because he has it on him now in the cop
car
and then they bring him back and let him
go in another car oh my god
my boy billy can fortune he died
actually too ate a bunch of pills and
[ __ ] died but um oh god rest in peace
it got dark
oh yeah rest in peace forever bro all
right let's rename some wrestlers you
[ __ ]
okay i will start off with um
[Music]
i mean i could easily start with the rat
king myself but i'm gonna go with
uh fake ass wrestlers mystic rick
i feel like you've already lost he
doesn't count okay i didn't give you
another chance though
i didn't think so either uh i'm gonna go
with um
the big boss man brother going with that
macho man randy
savage okay i like that i'm gonna go
with that easy peasy
yep nissi mr hulk hogan
himself yeah with that pad thai hairdo
i'm gonna go with that jake the snakey
oh i think you need to get that
select trim like your boy right here
from brutus
i'm gonna go with what theo does with
his nuts the bulldog
[Laughter]
who's the bulldog oh the [ __ ] bulldog
bring that up
the british bulldog baby
the british bulldog is way different
than
the bulldog he's known as the bulldog
the bulldog if you're in britain i think
he's just goes by the bulldog
and uh my mom's from england and i'm
half english
count it oh what else you got another
thing brendan's half
um i'm gonna go with uh yeah boy
dusty rhodes uh all right how about you
hit you with the
ultimate wire okay i'm gonna go with the
damn dusty road's about to die yeah
he's dead he didn't he's dead i could
tell by that picture
uh i'm going to go with your boy hacksaw
yeah well they call me this in the
sheets how about
the animal
the animal the animal come on talking
animal roadways
i'm going to go with uh i'm going to
support blm right here and go with coco
b oh i like it
how about i hit you with a little
undertaker
look at coco though bro he was oh
with that parrot yeah that hot ass
parrot
yeah beautiful parrot all right i'm
gonna go with uh
flying right yeah will you
oh i like that but how about i hit you
right in the heart with brett the hitman
oh had to pull them out front of the bus
you threw them under last week huh
[Laughter]
who did you say huh flying brian
williams
it's flying brian pillman
[Music]
see theo's problem is he goes too
specific if you go vag we can just count
it but if you just had flying brian you
would have had it he said brian williams
though
that's pretty specific i was wondering
why you pulled that up
i was like i know brian williams lost
his job but is he in the wwe now
he is now gonna let it slide i don't
feel stupid you know
bro you know you weren't letting
anything slide bro you didn't know okay
that's why i won
baby yeah because i've never heard of
brian williams in wwf
but here's the crazy part yeah nick
hadn't been here and it was just you and
i guess we wouldn't kept going
yeah cause i want to keep going
so you guys ain't [ __ ] brothers
you guys
that's from mighty ducks they're the
bushwhackers no type in bass brothers
look we also gave this dude the bulldog
brothers
that yeah the bass brothers that's
bushwhackers
bring up bass brothers yeah bring up the
bass brothers you'll get a video game
no they're right there dude there they
are wwe's the bash brothers oh
no one ever these guys though are the
guys these are the bushwhackers
oh yeah yeah yep i'm with you the bash
brothers ain't shy
i was gonna hit you with that yokozuna
wow i wasn't hitting you with that sable
what's up bro you don't know [ __ ] about
savage have you ever heard of these fake
ass
i was gonna hit with eve gracie bro
ronda rousey
all right china blazer china
china's one too rest in peace
oh they're married yeah they're married
now really
her her and him yep they've been
together for a hot second
what's her name
uh i don't know yeah she's a wrestler
wwe champion wwe
diva i should say well
it's fine one again man that burgers hit
me slowing me down my brain you
[ __ ] your pants no i don't feel like
anything's wrong with my body i just
feel like my brain got slowed out
you didn't say brian williamson wwe i
said flying
brian williams dude what a great name
who is it [ __ ] who's in an
announcer who also wrestled in college
didn't he yeah
yeah can you look up if you wrestle
did brian williams wrestle
in college
i went to matt damn he went to matter
day matter
no you didn't wrestle yeah but hold on
go back he said he was a busboy at
perkins pancake house
hey you know they wrestle after work
hey you know he wrestled some lies in
that helicopter when he said he was in
the war remember that that's why he got
fired what about this so he suffered an
accident that left him with a crooked
nose that could have been wrestling
my first job was also bus boy at perkins
pancake house and i
we wrestled that night
but they're all game
that ain't wrestling that's some gay
[ __ ] man that's beautiful man i think
you guys are doing it
dude a couple of men meeting up after
work to make sure everybody's doing okay
taking the aprons off and wrestling over
pie
that's just gay bro
bro it's it's only if you're gay after
you wrestle
that's fair what else you got just that
was only half true we didn't wrestle but
i was busboy at perkins
[Music]
is